This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
[music] diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
[music] FDA. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of the
individual. Results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health [music] or income. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to [music] share the teachings
of a founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in [music] Plant and soil
sciences, doctor of veterary medicine,
four post-doates and pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. [music]
Testimonials are shared as individual
experiences of the individual. Results
vary and may not be typical. We do not
make any claims regarding [music] health
or income. As an empowered individual,
you do have options available. We are
honored to continue to share the
teachings of a founding father of the
science of epigenetics, [music] Dr. Joel
Wallik, Bachelor of Science in Plant and
Soil Sciences, Doctor of Veterary
Medicine, Ford Post-Does and Pathology,
Naturopathic Doctor.
>> [music]
>> Hello and welcome everyone to Daily with
Doc and Becca. My name is Ruth Ellen
Sanchez. I'm going to be your host
today. Let's go ahead and open up that
Zoom room door and let everyone in.
And today we have a really special guest
on, Ivan Ray. Ivonne is a functional
medical nutrition and micro current pain
specialist, boardcertified amino acid
therapy for brain health.
Former military, that did not come out
as smooth as I wanted to. Former
military Ivonne has worked with pain
free for life beta testing research um
where microcurrent protocols are
developed
erasing pain holistic centers where she
assists in training interns and is
nutritional director team member at
Theta Wellness Brain Health Center in
Sacramento. And as an educator, she
teaches weekly classes on nutrition and
the use of frequency devices to expedite
the healing
curve.
She also volunteers to work in with
other clinicians to broaden her scope of
knowledge and research. Quarterly, she
travels and presents the impact of
nutrition and frequency devices for
natural, alternative, and home pain
relief. That is amazing. I can't wait to
hear her story. Um, first I need to say
this. This program is for educational
purposes only. The content is not
intended to diagnose, treat, or cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of the
individual. results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
choices and that is why we have cool
guests on like Ivonne to help you have
choices. So, Ivonne, I'm going to add
you.
Hello. How are you today?
It's good to see you all again. Um I'm
glad that we're back at it.
Me, too.
>> We didn't have another talk.
>> Yes. I'm very excited.
>> Yeah. Well, um I appreciate you, you
know, inviting me back. I know today
we're really going to be talking about
lung health and um
uh this would actually be part two of my
docu series that uh I've been putting
together. And a lot of times people
probably don't even Think about this,
but we breathe something like 20,000
times a day.
And you know, the machinery that goes
behind that, uh, if it's not working
properly, if it's, you know, can't
expand,
um, or contract back,
uh, there is, um, other ensuing problems
that will happen.
I'm looking forward to hearing all about
this amazing process that you have.
>> Thank you.
>> So, I'm going to turn it over to you.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Okay. And I have questions that
intermittently.
>> Okay.
>> So, I think we have a few slides. Let me
know when those are pulled up.
>> Okay.
Give me one second.
Lots of buttons here.
All right, slide one is up.
All right. Well, I'm going to have you
jump to maybe slide two or no, go, you
know what? Go ahead and stay there and
we're just going to talk uh just a brief
minute. Um, I know that uh um Doc and uh
I think I've heard Ben talk about this
too, but um
the fact that when we're talking about u
lungs, bronchial health, that can
include any number of health challenges,
bronchitis,
um uh emphyma,
uh longhaul
uh COVID um asthma and
all of these have a nutritional
deficiency component and what can happen
is if we uh you know are missing those
nutrients we now have these problems
what I have found is when we um
if that isn't enough and you need to
kind of come in and have an assistant.
This electrical of the body we can tap
into.
And so earlier I was just talking about,
you know, talking uh or breathing 2,000
times a day. Um if we really take a look
at, you know, the how we can help our
lungs, the first thing that we want to
understand is one, um it's typically
nutrition that uh uh gets us into
trouble. uh that's usually the start of
the symptom of a tissue issue. Um and
when we look at
this slide right here, the next step if
somebody is not getting better, let's
look at the um the electrical component
uh of the body. Now here there's just a
couple slides and you know people often
will ask you know how how do I check you
know the voltage of my tissue. Um this
is happening in hospitals
uh every day and they're using
electrical equipment to to check several
different parts of the body. Uh one
would be the heart. uh if anybody has
ever had neuropathy and they go in and
their uh docs will actually test them.
Um I think that one's called an EMG,
electrical um muscle uh stimulator. And
they're they're trying to capture two
things on that. not only the voltage but
also the heartbeat uh at the foot
because if something's going ary there
um you know they're going to start to
try to trace that back and um there's uh
heart brain uh neuropathy I know I'm
missing something oh kidneys they can
electrically um try to determine
information about uh kidneys as well so
if we move into the the Next slide.
And that that EKG real quick that is um
again just helping the
body understand where is there any
electrical
um
blocks or areas of resistance. And so we
are using tools to do the same thing but
they're frequency specific. They're also
tissue specific, but kind of an
all-in-one.
Um,
so one of the things that we first want
to look at somebody with health
challenges are um how are those uh lung
challenges affecting their O2 sats? Now
I I did a little bit of research and
when we talk about O2 saturation that's
about the oxygen that is in the blood
flowing through the body. We know again
uh if there is not regarding um lung
health if there is not enough nutrients
uh you can begin to have a problem. And
then if you take a look at the top, I
think is um it it talks about there is a
uh um a website there, an NIH website,
and there's over 120 reviews on this. Um
I'd like love for people to go in and
just educate themselves, but it really
discusses uh what Dr. Wallik has talked
about before, the Keshan disease. There
was also another name called the um and
somebody correct me if I'm misstating
this uh there's Keshan and the other one
was
um Kishin I
and that is a condition about the bones
and the joints and the need for these
specific supplements which would be
selenium and essential fatty acid. ids.
Has anybody ever heard of that one
before?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Pretty cool. And it it it's in
here in this um in this study that I've
noted. So, I think it's worthwhile to go
in and and and check this stuff out. Uh
if we move into the next slide, one of
the things that I'm trying to help do is
uh we during the beginning and mid 2020,
2021, 2022,
we kept seeing people that were having
all of these incredible health
challenges
um that were lungreated
And
I wanted to try to get out the word that
hey, we can help with those that
inflammation, that swelling, that edema
that's happening in the lungs.
Uh so one of the things I've done I've
I'm showing just a couple testimonials
here
of people that uh either are part of the
lung study that I'm doing
uh or that came in and with the study it
includes the nutrition. So we're using
nutrition and the microcurrent together.
My goal here is just to show or prove
the efficacy
in one treatment, how we can begin to
increase the oxygen. What happens in the
ERS is that they get so impacted and
inundated the only thing that they can
really do in the moment is try to get
oxygen on them, give them a steroid.
Uh but these tools, these protocols are
they're they're imagine one of the first
athome
um uh interventions is somebody using an
inhaler.
So I truly believe that if we can prove
the efficacy of this through the
clinical trials uh or these clinical
studies right now they are set up for
clinical trials but you know we'll see
what happens uh we probably have
close to 75
uh but here we have Kim she came in and
for over a year just couldn't breathe
and over the year her health was
continuing to fail.
uh I did invite her on the call today,
so I'm hoping that she may be able to uh
make it and show up and actually kind of
share her own testimony.
But uh you know, you can see um that for
over a year she was struggling. And this
is actually a video, but we don't have
it uh running, so uh we can't have her
tell her story. But with
um a few treatments with this uh you
know she was just up and running again
and her health again uh was no longer on
a downward spiral.
So um hopefully we'll hear from her at
the end.
Um let's go to the next slide.
And I think what we have here I
mentioned a little bit earlier. Oh, and
here is where I think I have the um uh
uh the the link. But it's it's really
incredible because with this um it's not
only about um uh essential fatty acids
or selenium. Uh it's not also only about
lungs but you'll see that you know
muscle weakness, thyroid challenges,
infertility, immune dysfunction can
happen without these just these
particular nutrients. Obviously we
always believe in all of the essential
nutrients. But take a look at these um
uh reports here. Uh let's go to the next
one.
Thank you. Uh
in our clinical trials, uh this gal
here, she was on oxygen and basically
was told that she would be oxygen
dependent. Uh one of her biggest
challenges is that she could not go up
into the high altitudes. Here in the
Northern California area, uh we have
something called the grapevine. Um also
if you want to uh visit, which is only
about an hour and a half from us, uh
these were challenges that she couldn't
do. So getting over to uh Southern
California, she was unable to do. Uh you
know, she retired, traveling was her
dream. Um and someone told her about
what we were doing at the clinic. The
first thing we did for her was, as you
guys remember, we've talked about hidden
hunger before, right? That's where those
nutrients we can be um overfed but
malnourished
and that that's what was happening here.
So, the first thing we started to
address was the nutrition and then
shortly after that we started the
microcurrent protocols for her. And um
because this was going to be a long-term
um you know she did purchase a home
device. A lot of people use these much
like the inhaler um as a first response
uh to reduce the swelling, the
inflammation, the stuff that's going on
that is uh creating a um an episode for
them. And um you know she now travels.
It's pretty cool. Um, over the grape
vine to Tahoe and but what is even more
exciting is she is not needing her daily
oxygen
and uh you know she does keep it around
as precautionary.
Um but uh you know these are the things
the body is also electrical. We're not
just chemical but we're also electrical
and that chemical
uh needs the electrical. So, if you're,
you know, uh, like me, I was utilizing
all of the nutrients and I got
significantly better, but there were
still a couple challenges. And it was
working on that electrical side that got
me over that proverbial hump
um, and just moving me into a better uh,
a better state of health. Um, here, uh,
if you want to move to the next slide,
we have, uh, Dr. Dom
and uh we'll have to try to maybe see if
we can bring these or get these videos
for folks here in his clinic. He does
address um long COVID and he is an
expert in you know just managing uh
understanding and recovering from these
um uh syndromes. and we use uh the same
devices and tools um that he does. Uh
and he was a army surgeon
um flight surgeon and um uh just you
know
is is utilizing microcurrent. I think we
talked about him in the first series uh
of our docue series which was the spinal
injuries and the incredible work that he
is doing there with nutrition and with
um uh microcurrent
let's see let's what's our what's our
next one so when we talk about
microcurrent
um I I want to just first address a lot
of people will talk about a much older
um technology called the TENS unit. So,
um microcurrent and electrical
stimulation came on the scene back in
the 1800s. So, this isn't new. It's been
around a while, but I wanted to make it
clear that you do not want to use a TENS
unit on the lungs. This is not what it
was designed for.
tends to do one of two things. They
either one um block a nerve signal, so
there's no real resolve or um
um regeneration.
The second thing that they do is they're
muscle stimulators.
So, do not use these on your lungs.
And if you take a look at the chart, you
get the opportunity to see a little bit
about how they're different. Now, I call
the tens the screamer and the
microcurrent the whisperer. And part of
the reasons are because one, it does not
yell at the body. It's actually
microcurrent is a thousand times less
than a tens. The waveform is different.
A tense unit is surface
um a microcurrent can get deeper
into the body's tissues
uh just and thus you know being able to
provide um greater healing uh and then
the more that your blood is filled with
those nutrients
because the microcurrent can help
increase blood flow.
uh Baylor and Stamford I believe it is
says by up to 400% to the area that
you're working on.
If you have quality nutrition in the
body, if you have any nutrition in the
body, imagine this. you're that tissue
issue that you're working on in the
lungs specifically,
we're going to be able to feed that
tissue up to 400 times more than it was
able to eat without that circulate
without that circulation.
Um, and again, there's there's a little
bit more um, you know, to this, but
that's why you got a little um a little
chart there for you. Let's move on to
the next slide.
Uh you might remember in part one of the
docue series Dr. Dom was talking about a
lady with uh Giamet syndrome and one of
the things that had happened with her
was that because of the nerve damage
um with the GBS,
it was impacting
um her ability to uh breathe.
And it was about 6 or 8 weeks after she
started the protocol with Dr. Dom that
uh she was able to um you know get back
to health and uh again using the
microcurrent as a first line of defense
but looking for not just a symptom
relief but that overall rebuild is what
what we really want here for people
right uh let's go to the next slide
and I started off just talking about um
you know in 2020 2021
uh working on this um clinical trial
and
uh you can see you know here I am just
uh it it was purely by accident I gotta
be honest
what happened here we were just offering
free classes and we took the protocols
that we were losing and we had 99%
had an increase in their O2 saturation,
their oxygen saturation. We tested four
different ways before and after, gave
them the nutritional um drink. Uh we did
this very specific microcurrent protocol
um helping to address inflammation, scar
tissue and then retested them again in
those four areas. We had all but one out
of about I think it was around uh 50 or
60.
uh we didn't get a change in his um uh
in the tests that we did uh but his he
said clearly the expansion and
contraction of the lungs was much better
and that's been about four years ago and
he is you know still touting um this
particular uh event that he attended and
how well the microcurrent worked for his
lungs. He ended up bringing his mom in
for his knee and other things. But uh um
let's take a look at some of those other
things that came out of this and and and
we're actually still working on this
study because my goal is that we would
um get
130 people that we can
um
test because there'll be about 30% that
will be thrown out. If you want to move
to the next slide.
So, we've been documenting oxygen
saturation. So, these are just some
success stories. Now, what I want you to
see in these pictures, if you can, these
are afterwards. Um, and and we do have
quite a few of these, but if you take a
look, you can see the 98%
on their O2, their their SO
um their their saturation oxygen
percentage, 98%.
I can't remember personally what they
were when they came in, but for the
clinical trial, uh
the ones that will matter were those
that were 95% or below.
And so these two were pretty happy. Um
Roy there, some of you guys might
remember recognize him, Mr. Happy Feet.
Uh and if you remember, he had 70%
vascular insufficiency.
And obviously if he wasn't breathing
well that's going to impact the rest of
the circulation in his body. So this was
around 2020 for him. And then in 2021 we
started working on the rest of the
vascular system. Uh because of the
damage that that had occurred. Uh they
were actually talking about amputating.
uh they just had not decided were they
going to amputate from the knees down or
below the knee.
And then we got Ewald who is a
construction
>> [clears throat]
>> um and uh he's pretty happy because he
can go back to he went back to work.
Let's take a look at the next slide.
Here we have a couple folks that have um
you can see you know whether the damage
is caused by you know virus
environmental
um first giving the body the raw uh
minerals and then we add a little
frequency to boost that ATP
increase the circulation reduce the
um inflammation
uh address the fibrous tissue.
We got a win-win situation.
All right, what's next?
Here we've got another one. Now, here
you'll see a little bit part of the
protocol also includes
not only working directly on the lungs
and we use um our tools.
Some of you might recognize
some people call this a magic wand.
>> They can't see you right now. So, we'll
show them after you're done with the
slides.
>> Oh, okay. Thank you.
>> Unless you want me to show you real
quick and then go back to the
>> No, no, no, no, no. [laughter]
Okay.
Um, but uh
what was I saying? I got myself lost.
Sorry about that.
>> Oh, you were talking about working on
the lungs and how you use your tools.
>> Yeah. So um in this slide you can
clearly see though we're working on um
uh the meridian points and so many will
know about traditional Chinese medicine.
Anytime you have a lung challenge
besides nutrition, you'll hear
consistently from doc, from Ben,
pharmacist Ben, uh um
uh meridian points, um essential oils,
um nutrition, utilize all of these
things, layer them to help you through
the challenge because a lot of people
are unaware that if you cannot get the
breath and the filtration happening
within the lungs.
It's a slow demise for the rest of the
tissue. So, it's critically important.
It's not just about getting on oxygen.
It's about figuring out how to um
reverse and then repair and eventually
rebuild the tissue of the lungs. It is a
filtration system just like your kidneys
and your liver.
And so again those meridian points are
very key. Uh next slide.
So with our clinical trial on average we
have been able
uh to increase the oxygen circulation
uh by about 3.2 two.
And that's actually pretty huge because
again, whether the damage is from, you
know, viral, environmental, whatever, um
we're looking at
um increasing that. And it's interesting
because we actually uh continue to
[clears throat] um uh test just the
oxygen saturation
for the next three days. and the oxygen
stayed in those upper levels. So that is
really exciting again the potential for
an at-home
you know first response
keeping people out of the ER
and keeping the impact of you know the
our ERS are really oversaturated. It is
it is a problem. And so my hope is that
as we continue to build on this that
we'll be able to um um have more just uh
find these tools. Uh let's go to the
next um slide.
So, here um is just a flyer of
the participation
for the clinical trials. And you'll see
a little bit next to it, we're talking a
little bit about some of the hertz or
the frequencies that we're going to use
specifically
on the body. So the beautiful thing
about these tools is they will one
address the specific tissue. So we're
going to work on the lung, but then we
bring in also
what is the problem with that lung. And
if you're looking at most
uh
lung challenges, it's going to be
inflammation which if stays too long
creates edema fluid in the lungs. So the
goal is to first start to drop that
swelling that inflammation.
uh we touch every part front, sides,
back of the tissue
and um
and then just you know look to bring
better health.
What's that next slide? I think we're
done.
And then there's just a little way to
contact us.
Are you coming back on?
>> There we go. Yeah, it just I have to It
seems like I have to double click
everything today. [laughter]
Those are fantastic, great slides and
great stories of um personal like
evidence of actual repair and health.
I'm always blown away by the
microcurren. [laughter]
>> Well, and you know, I I you know, like
you, I'm also blown away just by the
nutrition. I mean, for those of you that
are familiar with, you know, rare earth,
uh, forbidden cures, um, let's play
doctor. I mean, very clearly, and these
are not the only books where this is,
this information is stated, but these
are great books because I actually have
them in my clinic. There are books that
I suggest to my clients as reading
material because my goal is to educate
um the microcurrent as great as it is it
cannot rebuild the missing tissue. So we
have to come in and we created this you
know I just hey the marriage of uh uh
chemical and uh biology and technology.
We are electrical beings. The electrical
is required to move anything chemical in
the body. So if the if the body is low
in voltage,
you can really struggle to have
something actually that you're doing um
get full benefit.
Does that make sense?
>> Yes.
Yes, it is. because it's very important
you have
the building materials like you call it
the nutrients in there cuz you know
you literally I know from for u personal
experience of going through something
hard and then not taking my supplements
and how awful I felt and couldn't figure
out what was wrong and then I realized I
hadn't taken my supplements for weeks
and um why I don't I don't even know But
um it made a huge difference for me. And
in the beginning when I first started
with the um Young Japanese uh the Tangy
Tangerine the healthy body start pack I
was so sick prior to that that uh and I
couldn't get better and it was just like
this whole evolution took place and I
started to feel better. I started losing
weight. My hair started growing in
better and my skin cleared up and just a
whole bunch of things. So, we do have a
couple of questions.
>> The the return to life, right? The
>> return to life, you know, and it's
really it's really interesting, you
know, and just talking about like just
say lungs or whatever you were dealing
with, but you know, uh who was it that
said it? Does anybody remember the
Iceman um Utsie?
Uh this just made me think of this. They
said that he had black lung
uh probably from all of the campfire
um smoke. And uh but when you say about
your nutrition,
we know that like in the Kon disease um
that's selenium, good fats, uh the
cystic fibrosis
um
from this when when it's not happening,
we get a drop in oxygen or like you you
saw a drop in everything, didn't you? I
did.
>> Yeah,
>> I really did.
>> And now, can I ask you a personal
question?
>> You can ask. [laughter]
>> Can I put you on the spot?
>> Sure. Um because I had this myself and
and I'll share after you, but what
happened that you
I'm going to use the word forgot your
nutrients
because I know that happened to me. How
do you for I I this happened to me. How
did I forget to take my nutrients? I was
going through something and I don't know
if life just got too busy or if I felt
overwhelmed.
Um
you know for me it was about my bone
health that was and
you know the inflammation that was
occurring.
>> Um
there have been times I forget to take
my medicine or vitamins sorry which I
consider
>> we could look at we we could look at
>> I consider it medicine I I suffer
severely if I don't have it. Um
uh so there are times that I just get
really busy. Uh one time I went on I had
to go away to work and I completely
forgot all of my supplements in my
bedroom and I felt it and I had to order
stuff to come in.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
so mainly it's that I mean there was
another thing that happened and um
I'm not ready to talk about that
publicly.
>> My apologies. Yeah,
>> it's all good. It's all good. Someday I
will, but right now I'm just not there.
Um, but it's very important and I know
that it makes a difference
every day
to feed your body in a way that with
America's food supply,
there are no almost no nutrients. And
you know, people grow things in their
gardens and different things, but if
there's no calcium in the soil, you're
not going to have it in your spinach.
>> You know, you can eat organic all you
want, but you still need to supplement
just because, you know, they put those
dams up so farlands don't get floods
anymore and it doesn't stir up all the
soil and make take things from like way
on top of the mountain down into the
plains and different areas. So, like
how could we not feed our bodies like
with nutrition? Good nutrition.
>> Yeah. Well, and you and I are of the
opinion simply because of that whole
hidden hunger at play. We recognize
um I'm going to play it safe and and
we're going to take these because I
recognize just like you said, it's not
in the soil. There are lots of other
things in the soil that we don't want to
be even when we're eating, you know,
organic. That organic food is not any
more nutrientdense than commercially
grown food. It just has a little less on
it.
>> Um, you know, being a survivor of Camp
Leune, um, I am very,
>> you know, keen on that, trying to, you
know, keep things out of my body. Uh but
yeah, that that that's that's hidden
hunger. That's exactly what that is. And
and we're, you know, we're taking in
plenty calorically, but we're actually
malnourished.
>> Yes. Very malnourished.
It's um I hate to say this, but um there
are times that I look at someone and
they weigh 500 lb or more or less, you
know, they're they're over 300 lbs and I
just think, my god, that person is
literally starving to death and they
don't even know it.
>> And they don't even know it because I
had somebody say that
>> to me.
>> Yeah. and and I now recognize and truly
believe um you know it's while there may
be an emotional attachment, it's not an
emotional problem. And I learned that
when I got my certification for um brain
health uh using amino acids. I mean, so
this isn't the only platform that truly
[clears throat] knows. they're just
focused on, you know, brain health and
how those amino acids if they get low in
the brain, you get mood swings, you get
behavioral, you get and they do call it
a chemical imbalance because it is.
>> Yes.
>> And to try to feed that, remember the
body will take the lion share of the
amino acids, but the brain needs a lion
share. So if you drop low here, it's
almost impossible to eat enough. you
really do need to supplement with um
things that can help rebuild those
neurotransmitters
and reestablish which most of those
neurotransmitters those are hormones and
if you don't have good fats baseline of
a hormone right
>> sorry we're we're talking about
something else aren't we [laughter]
>> no it's all important because I I've
been increasing my amino acids and it's
helped me significantly so it's
And did you know that they're a natural
anti-inflammatory?
>> Yes, I can tell you that for sure.
[laughter]
>> I used to I used to take something else,
you know, uh when I would have
migraines. I no longer have the
migraines like I once did, but on
occasion I have gotten them and I'll
actually take an extra six or so and
that will usually be enough along with
some minerals. But um that'll usually be
enough. And but I'm talking maybe two or
three times a year now. It's nothing
like it was before. It was two or three
days
>> um almost every month.
Um
so we do have a hand up and we have a
couple questions. So I'm gonna um go
ahead and ask Hattie to unmute.
>> Awesome. Thank you, Ellen.
>> You're welcome. Oh, I I apologize. I was
I missed 13 minutes of your presentation
and that was 13 minutes too much
information that I missed. I'll go back
and listen to the recording. But I'm
really interested in this microcurrent.
Um you you know I have a and because I
have a I seem like for some reason I'm
getting a number of clients that have
severe issues with asthma, COPD, and it
sounds like this is something that might
assist. I'm also glad that you talked
about the importance of the nutrients
because [clears throat] too many of um
too many of my friends are in this
thing. Well, if I just get a machine
um I got a woman that's going through
cancer, she's spending thousands on
hypobaric chambers and carrying on but
not the not the nutrients. And I don't
think you can you cannot you cannot
bypass the nutrients. They're too
important. So, I'm really glad that you
mentioned that. But I would love to have
more information about this microcurren.
If not now, I can get back with you
later. And I want to know if you've used
it around kidneys, i.e. getting people
off diialysis. And how long does it
take? What have you seen in your
experience with people with COPD and
asthma and all that kind of stuff? How
long did it take to see a difference?
>> Well, I'm not sure if you saw
um our gal our story. She was um on
oxygen when she came to us
and I would say it was for her
maybe six months before she went from
carrying the oxygen
uh daily to keeping it with her but not
using it. Um,
and then I had a gal, Rose, 90 years
old, told that she was going to be on
oxygen.
Um, and she had uh quite the long lead
that uh, you know, went through her
apartment. Oh, we were probably three or
four months.
And um she was able to slowly she would
go to the dining room to eat and come
back three times a day, use her oxygen.
But somewhere after the fourth month,
she was able to not only just go to eat
and come back, but she started getting
um and she was engaged before, but she
would go like they go play cards or they
would do whatever um activity was
happening at the senior community. And
so now she could eat and do an activity
>> without going back to the room for
oxygen. So everybody's a little bit
different. Um but I truly believe that
you know it will ultimately be the
nutrition.
The microcurrent is wonderful. Uh
without the nutrition there are
certainly people that are using this as
a tool. There are practitioners like
myself. We see people coming in. They're
not purchasing a home device which in my
opinion makes more sense
uh cost effective. Um, I even encourage
my clients if you want to work with me,
you know, here's how I work. It's a
twofur.
And you know, if I mean, if if they
actually start on my rebuild program, I
include a free session every month
because to me, the nutrition is that
important. And I and I want to make that
clear. And so they come in for a 15 20
minute session for those that are on the
rebuild using the nutrition.
>> Awesome. I want to learn about the
rebuild.
>> Okay. [laughter]
>> Peace and blessings. I So I can reach
out to the email. I think you had it on
the slide.
>> Um absolutely. Or my website. Um I
I can say it here. I'm not sure what
uh can we put it in the chat with them?
>> Yeah, let's do that.
>> Yes, we could do that.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> Thank you, Haddie. That is an amazing
story. It made me think of my aunt who
was had the long tube for oxygen and uh
I miss her a lot. I do. So, and you know
the microcurrent it can help quiet
um that pain that hunger
uh the tissue is you know hungry for
air. Um and we start to reestablish any
potential resistance of electrical or
loss of electrical or block of
electrical
um you know in the body
and because remember that inflammation
begins to take the form of congestion
which then just creates another problem.
So the earlier we can get it, the better
uh or I should say uh in my experience,
the faster somebody has that recovery
because we're dispersing the congestion
um and getting it, you know, out of the
body.
>> Yeah, that's very good. You got to get
things out for sure.
>> Go ahead. I was just going to say and I
know you and I talked about this um and
you know after you disperse the
congestion you know the the what
initially happens is those white blood
cells they're coming to the rescue right
they but the electrical will kind of
signal it'll give this move out uh
clearing of the white blood cell signals
um
they want to come and try to help but
It's kind of like the Battle of the
Bulge. If you remember the picture of
the Battle of the Bulge, the Marines um
the the soldiers were coming in and they
were trying to establish
um and plant the American flag. And to
do so, soldiers were dying and they were
crawling over those soldiers. And that's
kind of what's happening when you get
inflammatory response that doesn't stop.
Much like fibrosis, in cystic fibrosis,
you get scarring that just isn't
stopping. The body almost goes into, you
know, over construction mode simply
because there's actually things that are
missing. But we want to um
move out or send out that move out
signal by removing the inflammation. And
then those white blood cells uh which
the body's you know actively producing
people don't even realize you got
inflammation. You have an immunity
challenge that's happening in the
background in the bones. Um
and the electrical can kind of come in
and augment that.
>> Yes.
Right. So, we do have a couple of
question a question and a comment on um
YouTube.
Um so, Mr. Rod who's out there on
YouTube says, "Yevan's approach really
works. I've personally experienced it
for myself. She helped me help with my
knee when I could hardly walk. In a
matter of days, I was much better."
Awesome. That's [clears throat] awesome
testimonial. Very good. And then um
there is a four-part question
that um
>> let me write this down.
>> Yeah. Okay. I know. I would do that too
[laughter] because it says right here.
It says ask all at once. Let her know
it's a four-part question. [laughter]
All right. So why would Are you ready?
Okay.
Why would someone get lung scar tissue?
What can be done
when using microcurrent? Why would there
be tons of flem?
I have an answer for that. Mu should a
person expect to get better overnight or
will it take time?
>> You have an answer for that?
>> Why would there be flem?
>> Yep.
>> Yes. because the body is releasing
things and the only way to get stuff out
of the lungs is to cough it up and get
it out. That's my personal opinion. I
don't know if it's [laughter]
but usually that's what that means. If
you got something in your lungs and
you're working on, then your body is
going to release just like if you were
doing something else, you need to do
foot soaks and different things to, you
know, and you know, if you're doing a
detox, the body is going to make you go
to the bathroom a lot.
>> Yes. [laughter] Yeah. Um,
now I know in re let just for the first
question, uh, it was why would scar
tissue do what? Why would someone get uh
scar tissue in their lung? I'm It's It
says get lung scar tissue.
>> Oh, okay. Um well, what happens is the
body is constantly trying to repair
itself.
And let's just start like I said with uh
you know the fact that first there may
not be enough nutrients
for the body to help itself.
uh and you know you have the mechanism
uh that utilizes the prostaglandins and
nerve control. Um there's the vagus
nerve that can be uh part of what may be
going on.
Um
and so you know scar tissue
this might be better better one for doc
but ultimately the bricks and mortar
uh to physically repair the lung matrix
and the air sacks just isn't there but
the body's trying to repair it and so
you get some call it an overactive
um
you know overactive tissue issue is what
they'll say is happening. U but we
understand that to be working a little
differently.
And then what could be done? What could
be done with what I I got part of the
questions but
>> okay so it says why would someone get
scar tissue? Uh then it was what can be
done for the lung scar tissue? Oh. Uh,
so
remember we were talking earlier about
frequencies.
There is a frequency specific to scarred
tissue and um we address it using that
and what it does scar tissue you know uh
you're looking at the fashcia and that's
where the electrical travels.
Um,
if I've I've mentioned this before on
YouTube, there's a wonderful
YouTube video called strolling through
the fashca. If you get a chance, go take
a look at it. Uh, but that faucia
when it begins to scar, it once had much
like grain of wood. It had a pattern. Um
but when it starts to scar it looks more
like a bowl of spaghetti and so
electrical can't come through that. It
literally becomes like this beaver dam
in a river.
So what can be done again with the use
of um uh tools like microcurrent and
there are other ways that people have um
neutralized
a scar because the one thing about a
scar is it becomes a conductor. So it
becomes conductive which means scar
itself can be a reason for somebody's
pain because that electrical will build
up in class. Uh we would go around with
an ohm meter and um our doc Dr. Hashe
said he had a gentleman who had so much
power in his scar it was something like
don't quote me on this 1.4 or seven or
either way it was enough to light a
light bulb. That's how much he had in
that scar tissue. And they did a
treatment about a 15minute treatment.
And not only did that electrical
conductivity
uh go down, but so did his pain.
And then the flem, the flem is it's the
fluid that begins to build up. It's the
swelling. It's the white blood cells.
It's your body's trying to come help
itself. They die off. Now they're
considered toxins and so you get this
thing called edema and oftent times
there's anyway there's cytoines and
it's happening all in these little sacks
and
and the fluid builds up
and uh did I finish that question?
Um let's see. Should a person expect to
get better overnight or will it I or
will it
>> much? Yeah, much like we talked about
earlier, everybody's different, but the
fact that there is a way that we can
begin to restore
uh breathing
um uh is pretty phenomenal. You know,
outside of using an inhaler and which
does it's a vasod diilator, but it's not
really doing anything to help the
tissue. it's not addressing scar tissue
um
>> or viral load if that happens to be the
reason for the lung challenge.
>> Okay. Excellent. You did great and I was
wrong. [laughter]
>> Oh no, you No, you were right on.
>> Okay, good. Very good. Um,
so we have a hand up and then I had a
couple questions that we can get to in a
minute. Okay. Um,
so Belle, if you would like to unmute.
>> Great to have you with us again, Yavon.
>> Oh, it's good to hear your voice. How
are you?
>> Uh, doing much better. Learning more on
using the unit. I just wanted to say
that uh my wife and I, we went down in
December uh in three treatments. We went
through pain level up to a 12 sometimes
and we went down to a four. We stayed
there for four and a half weeks
and I rent rental is available from
Yavon. We rented that one for a you a
month and then purchased one.
And there are so many things that this
can do. There are thousands.
There are over 400 videos on learning to
use these. So it's like
just go to her website, look at what can
be done like curvature of the spine
can change dramatically as we stand up.
where she's talking about the sinfoid uh
noid uh bone there uh letting the nerves
flow through correctly through your neck
uh is just wonderful. I tell people if
you slightly are out especially your
neck area you
you you hurt but if you're out too much
you're actually paralyzed. And so these
are not miracle machines. They're just
light waves and sound waves and
frequencies that God put in our
universe. And we're harnessing those for
the individual tissues, individual
tendons, and everything in the body just
works all together. It's just great. Go
to the website.
>> Fantastic. Bill, I am so delighted that
you and your bride are just feeling
better and better. Keep it up.
>> Well, what I appreciate that, but what
people will ask, well, how long does it
take? Is this going to take a week or
two? No. It's taken me 74 years to feel
as bad as I do. So, can I expect things
turn around on a dime? No. But let's be
a realistic. What is is work daily with
it. Like the vagus nerve, one of the the
most important nerve in the body. We do
those treatments multiple times a day,
four times a day. Anyway,
and there's other things that we need to
do. Anyway, thanks for allowing me to
share.
>> Thank you, Bill. Thank you.
>> That's awesome.
>> All right. Um,
that was that was good. I I love to hear
stories like that. But and that's one
thing that Phil said that a lot of
people they just think, "I'm going to do
this. I'm going to be good in a week.
I've had it for 35 years. I'm going to
be good in a week. And it's like, no, it
does. Even with nutrition, it takes time
because your body has to release,
repair, and and in whichever cycle it
does that, you know. Um,
it took me a long time. It didn't happen
overnight to get, you know, lose weight,
be able to walk. I mean, when I first
started, I couldn't even walk. I wish I
would have known you then. [laughter]
Oh my god, that was horrible. My leg
would not bend. I was a limo driver for
um since 2010 and I started doing sedan
work
and uh that is, you know, I'm used to
people being all the way back there and
instead they're right behind me. and I
would go to the airport and pick
somebody up, take them to an office
building, go back to the airport, pick
somebody up, take them to a different
office building at a different town, and
then I would go home, go to the first
one, pick them up, take them to the
airport, and sometimes in between taking
these two people to and from the
airport, I might pick up three or four
other people. So, it was some days I put
300 miles on the car
>> and it was a lie. So, I could have
really used [laughter] it. Um, so you
did say something about um the
electrical current in in a scar and
that's why when um I have a cut on my
finger,
uh I was washing a glass. Never wash
glasses when you're mad.
And it was one of those hourgl shape
hourglass shape, you know. and I put my
hand in to get the and I've done it a h
100 times and I was I was really mad.
Don't do it when you're mad. Don't wash
dishes when you're mad. At least not the
knives and the glasses. Um,
but I took off part of my finger like I
lifted it up from from here to to there.
And um I had to go to the hospital
obviously [laughter]
and uh the bottom part was thin where it
got cut. And by the time I was at the
hospital,
it um that tissue had started to turn
like black, like it was dying already,
you know, and so for several I won't go
into the but they were able to fix it
and that part, you know, healed and
everything. Um,
but for I don't know, five years, if I
hit it just wrong, it would send an
electrical current up my whole arm. And
um, I I learned to be very careful. It
doesn't do it anymore. So, um, I think
one of the questions was, and my phone
keeps closing on me, is um,
where is it?
So you talked about
scars having like a current. So how do
we how can I check my own tissue
voltage? That's what it
>> Ah, yes. Yes. Yes. So um
well real quick just to uh when you said
something about you know hitting that in
the nerve
we have to understand the perspective
that we are an an electric body you know
or there there's a book out there by uh
Dr. Robert Becker, the body electric.
And I'm just going to remind you a
couple things. If you, you know, if you
take a balloon and you rub it on
somebody's head, you know, you got
static. If you scooch across the carpet,
uh, you know, we are carrying that
electrical charge.
And um so but I'm glad that you uh uh
you know you got to recognize [laughter]
and the nerve the nerve is is is what we
need for um
uh you know sensation and for function
and so
ask your qu your question again. Sorry I
got a little bit sidetracked.
>> No it's okay. is how can I check my own
tissue voltage?
>> Oh, okay. Yeah. So, um
that's a great question. uh ear when we
started I commented about there's
several ways that they will test your
electrical
and you know um we're not just a
collection of parts but there are you
know uh there there's a circuit there's
a circuit board and healthy tissue has a
very specific voltage that has been
measured this is information that is
known you can look it up but to check
the voltage of tissue your tissue
issues. We use these microcurrent
um tools with um uh a BOF feedback and
and this is a closed loop neurom
modulation. So, not only does it reach
the brain, but it comes from the brain
back down to the affected tissue. And
kind of like a EKG that we were talking
about, ECG, you know, uh they'll put 12
leads on you, checking your um heart for
electrical, you know, going to the
furthest regions and back and are there
any blocks? Right. So, or like an ohm
meter, uh, your electrician comes and
he's going to take two prongs, put it
into the electrical outlet that maybe
you're having the complaint with. Is it
getting electrical from the box in the
bedroom all the way to the back of the
house to the breaker box and back? And
that will register information for him.
That's exactly what these tools do as
well. So, when I'm working with a
client, this particular device um has a
dual it has a dual smart chip. So, it
can calculate up to 3 million signals
per second. Uh these are not just random
numbers. Um, I think you've seen on some
of the other ones I I've shown, you
know, specifically you can see the
impedance, the conductivity, the
electrical blocks, and we just kind of
start from there. We don't diagnose
anything, but the goal is to try to
raise that voltage back up. And over the
next three or four days, the body will
take that, and it'll always drop back
down a little bit. But as we do this a
couple times, you're going to keep
getting a little higher. And especially
with the nutrition, it'll hold and you
have the opportunity for rebuild. And I
mean rebuild, not just repair where
they're going to sew up that little um,
you know, uh, stitch. We know through
regenerative medicine that we can
rebuild tissue. I've seen some of these
guys say you can go back as far as five
and even 10 years in rebuilding that
tissue. So, and that means if you've got
a tendon issue, we're talking that it's,
you know, it's not, let's say, it's all
worn out and it's thin and it's too
loosey goosey, right? It's stretched and
it's where where you can rebuild that.
Um, so it's going to come back to what
it's supposed to be, thicker, stronger,
not so it still be have that elasticity.
Uh um
uh but again, you know, most of this is
all and we should we should talk to
pharmacist Ben about this because it's
mostly in the beauty industry,
the regenerative
um use or uh the speak and and we're
talking about they call it anti-aging re
uh regenerative medicine, age reversal.
We've all heard of these terms, right?
>> Yes.
It's real.
>> That's amazing. So, yeah, that makes
sense because you see on TV different
devices that you can like run along your
jawline and up your neck to like tighten
it up without any kind of surgery and
different things.
>> And you know, uh, we heard Bill say
earlier about light.
What's really cool is when you in the
quantum realm
>> take a look at light or let's go back
take a look at electricity.
It is tiny tiny quantum quartz
>> amounts of light that are just pulsating
at such a speed that we can't even see
the separation.
You know, I truly believe between the
sun and the soil, we're required both.
The nutrients of the soil, the nutrients
of the sun, they create compounds like
antioxidants, CoQ10,
anti-inflammatories,
antis-spasmotics.
They create these compounds that are so
wonderful.
But I was one like many of us that we
were led to believe that there's only
one way that we can get those types of
compounds and it would be through a
petroleumbased
um pharmaceutical. But those
recipes are based off of
real chemicals that God made.
>> Yes,
I agree.
>> And the body mate. [clears throat] And
the body made. Because when these two
things come together in the body, we
then create other compounds, which is
really cool. Anyway, I'm trying to not
get too too geeky. [laughter]
I love it when you get geeky.
It's all good. Uh yeah, because like wi
with the sun on our b you know they they
say you know take your baby out and put
them in the sun and make sure their
abdomen is exposed for a few minutes so
that they can make vitamin D like and
that's one of the my belief
is that sunscreen usage everybody is
afraid to go out in the sun and let the
sun hit their skin and that people are
deficient in vitamin
Yeah.
>> So like sit in the sun for a little
while without any sunscreen.
>> It creates it creates hormones.
Dopamine, serotonin will be released. It
just offers so much. And the chemicals
that we're putting on us are then
creating another challenge that we we
don't even realize.
>> I love that. That sounds like
>> And you can create your own sunscreen.
uh if somebody writes me I I'll try to
find the um the actual recipe given by
uh another nutritional company um but it
is essential fatty acids uh I think it's
zinc and calcium and you you just just
like your sunscreen you would apply that
every couple hours you would actually
take these um nutrients take them to the
beach take them every couple hours if
you're out there all day long my husband
and I have not used sunscreen for years
and we might get a little pink. Um, but
we haven't had a real sunburn in a long,
long time. Not since we've started
nutrition.
So, that was
>> and he's a true redneck.
[clears throat]
>> So, that was zinc, essential fatty
acids, and calcium.
>> Yes. If I remember, if I But, you know,
look it up. I'm sure it is on YouTube. I
mean, I'm not the only way that, you
know, this this stuff I learned from
class. Um, cool.
>> But we use it.
>> That's awesome. I know that uh
Youngevity has mineral makeup and I put
that on and went to the beach and I
don't get sunburn on my face. I got
burned everywhere else, but not my face.
That stuff is amazing. [laughter]
And it doesn't have sunscreen in it.
It's just because it's minerals.
>> Yeah. Exactly.
All right. So, um it Oh my gosh, it's
4:14. [laughter]
>> Any other questions? We got to go.
>> Um I don't really have I I mean I have
the one question, but I think that's
going to be a long answer. Um
>> Okay.
>> Um and Zezy Captain Captain, hi
everybody out there in YouTube and
Rumble. Um he says, "Yep, they claim we
got get vitamin D from the sun, too."
Yep.
And okay um I think you already answered
it. It was about the other question I
had that I had was the um
they wanted to know more about how
microcurrent
quietins quiets the lungs the lung
information inflammation. Sorry I'm
stumbling over my words
>> but I feel like you answered that.
>> Yeah pre pretty much. Yeah, we we went
into that where we were talking about
the moving out of the inflammation, the
congestion
um and then uh um you know engaging the
brain. Uh so that remember the the one
thing we can do that's a little bit
different is when we engage the brain
especially when it's been a long-term
chronic condition at some point the
brain kind of sort of said hey you know
uh Ruth Ellen talk to the hand we got
work to do it it's pretty amazing how
how much somebody can be contending with
dealing with and yet they're still able
to move forward. um you know it's a
little bit of this uh pilots to do it
compartmentalize.
>> Perfect. Thank you.
>> All right. So any last thoughts that you
want to share to wrap that up? All
right. Well remember uh while
microcurrent is the signal that quiets
um the body still needs all the raw
materials for the actual rebuild.
Um and for lungs
uh we know the secret sauce will be some
additional selenium essential fatty
acids you know in addition to the
essentials
very necessary.
So Bruce says thank you Ruth Ellen and
Ivonne a lot of good information. Thank
you, Bruce.
And thank you for joining us, Olga.
And um I put Ivon's I put your website
on YouTube and Yvon can be found at Ivon
um for the number four, a better,
the letter U, and then the number
two.com and microcurrenacademy.com.
Awesome. Thank you so much. And uh I
can't wait for there's a part three,
right?
>> Yes.
>> I can't wait. I'm very excited. And we
will make sure to have videos. Um and
>> maybe maybe maybe we could ask, you
know, uh we could certainly talk about
the brain health.
>> Um and or maybe the eyes. What what what
might the consensus be? The eyes.
[laughter]
We talk about brains a lot, but not a
lot of people talk about the eyes.
>> So, maybe eyes and the brain. I'll
introduce you to s some um eye docs that
are using these tools in their practice
and then we add the m we add the
nutrition and you know it's it it's like
where we see in other regards things are
really improving. My own eye health is
better than it once was. I've shared
this before. I'll be sure to to actually
have my prescriptions on that. But my
old glasses were a 4.0 prescription.
Then I went down to a 2.5. These ones
are 175. Will I ever wear not wear
glasses? I don't know. But uh clearly my
eye health is better. I had two
aigmatisms which I no longer have.
>> That's amazing.
>> Yeah. And then and I haven't touched my
eyes for about two years. I
[clears throat] you know I just I'm not
taking the time. Anyway,
>> well, thank you so much for joining us
today. Um, and if I can get my co-host
to join me on screen, then we can um do
a quick wrap up. And um, so
you guys look for Ivonne at her websites
for the number four, a better you, the
letter u, and then the number two.com
and you can they can email you through
there, right?
Yes, there'll be a um uh contact us,
chat with us button.
>> Perfect. That is awesome. Um thank you
so much again. I have deep gratitude for
you just so much.
>> Thank you. It's very light.
>> Thank you. Um all right. So today's show
was sponsored by
dailywithdocandbecca.com.
If you would like to talk to a certified
holistic health coach, the phone number
is 855-9493377.
And if you would like to email us, you
can email us at
questions@dailywithdoc.com.
And um this program was for educational
purposes only and not meant to treat,
diagnose, or cure any diseases. And you
guys have options. So,
explore your options, [laughter]
watch replays. There's lots of good
information. Ivonne has some really good
replays on uh our different channels,
which is uh Daily with Doc and Becca
YouTube channel or is it daily with it
might be just daily with Doc on YouTube
channel and then critical health YouTube
channel. Critical health news YouTube
channel and then we have several
platforms on Facebook as well.
And um
I couldn't do this alone, so I'm
grateful for everyone that is here and a
couple people that couldn't be here. Um
we have Sherry who is part of our tech
crew and she helps set things up and
helps send the signal out and keeps an
eye on some the platforms. And we have
Mary who did double time today because
she is and Marilyn I know feel better.
Marilyn couldn't make it today, so feel
better, Marilyn. So, Mary has been our
speedy fingers today and she did a great
job. So, thank you, Mary. And then we
have Albert who is our gatekeeper and he
lets people in and he monitors things
and he picks up the slack where it's
necessary to pick up slack. So, thank
you, Albert. And we have Rod who was out
there on the different platforms helping
us out today.
And um AJ who is our uh digital
marketing director, he was here earlier
and he helps get us out on the different
platforms. And
he does a lot. We all do a lot. We all
work hard at helping everybody that we
can to have a better day and feel
better. So always remember to be kind.
You don't know what somebody's going
through. You know, a lot of times you
can't tell. So just be kind. And thank
you again, Yvon. And a big shout out to
Rebecca Dukes as well. But thank you.
And we will talk about when we're going
to get you on the show next.
Have a great day, everyone. And um we
will see you tomorrow.
And
I forget [clears throat] who our guest
is, but we have a show tomorrow, so
we're looking forward to seeing you.
Take care, everyone.
>> [music]
[music]
>> This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. [music] Results vary and
may not be typical. We do not make any
claims regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are [music]
honored to continue to share the
teachings of a founding father of the
science of epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science and Plant and soil
sciences, doctor of veterary medicine,
four post-doates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. [music] Results vary and
may not be typical. We do not make any
claims regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
[music] of Science and Plant and soil
sciences, doctor of veterary medicine
for post-doates and pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
>> [music]